this is really exciting I I posted
something on Twitter a while ago about a
really crazy number with a lot of a lot
of digits that are all the same and it
got a really huge response I just want
to share with you my experience with
this number let me draw the number for
you here we go here we go here we go and
in the words of Andrew Wiles I think
I'll stop there this number here all
nines you can see it in actual fact the
way that you describe this is as a rep
digit so in the math Canon you say rep
digit meaning repeated digit but what's
special about this there's two things
really special about this number is that
here down here there's one digit that's
changed so it's not a religion it's
called a near rep digit so it's just
really close so you know what I like to
call it brady i like to call it a glitch
i feel like it's a glitch because it's
not only a glitch number believe it or
not this is a prime number this here I
posted this on Twitter it really got
people going but you know what I thought
Brady I thought it sure made a mistake
I'd really like to check this number you
know as a mathematician that's what you
want to do you want to check it the only
problem is how do you check a number
like this I don't suggest you stick this
into the the Google entry line but to
actually work out if it was a prime or
not I actually needed to compactify it I
mean I needed to actually go just I
needed to actually transform it into
something that I could carry around so
this number has five hundred and six
digits and so the eight here is actually
if you count from the bottom from the
ones column and the tens column one
column if you get up you'll actually get
to the 254th
column so it's actually 254 along so
it's just over the halfway how can we
actually transport this in a way that
doesn't involve me writing out all these
nights
any ideas what's really cool about it is
the fact that they are nines
so if you add one to nine you get a ten
and if you add 1 to 99 you get a hundred
and if you add one to nine nine nine and
you get a thousand so we can actually
use that fact because if we can actually
get this as something to the power of
ten well that can really make things a
lot easier for us to handle so if we
think about it right this has five
hundred and six nines
so if we say ten take one is nine ten
squared take one which is a hundred take
one is ninety nine and ten cubed which
is three zeroes there take one is nine
nine nine then if we go dot dot and
you've got to love the dot dot dots
because you can put anything in tops we
can then say ten to the five zero six
take one is equal to let's just jump to
the chase a birdie is equal to nine nine
nine dot dot dot nine nine nine where
this happens to be five hundred and six
digits so that's kind of that except for
that I'm not a small change it actually
changes the value of the number quite a
lot doesn't what you mean changes the
value the quantity lucky if you were
going to buy that many eggs you're gonna
put this into eggs changing that from
1/8 we're changing that from a nine to a
night oh yeah yeah yeah
we change the number of legs you just
bought well you know what you're exactly
right and to actually work out by how
much you actually solving the problem 9
take 8 is 119 take 80 that's 10 9 100
take 800 is 100 piece of the Patagonia
so if we actually think there's a nine
right there in the two hundred and fifty
fourth position so what would that mean
that means that we're actually taking
away one with this many zeros so we're
going to imagine there's a one here and
then it's got all four every nine
there's basically a zero because that's
continuing what's going on here so now
what we're doing is we go ten to the
five zero six take one gives us the C of
nines and then we just want to take one
with a whole bunch of zero is to kind of
get it up to that point there so we're
basically taking away 10 to the 253 so
that's what that's equal to so it's that
take one to give us the nines take that
to take one away from that spot so yeah
so I found a way to actually carry it
around and talk to you this is the way
you talk to big numbers big prime
numbers like this to your friends you
don't go nein nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein it's some sort of Ali
gaeaf reference nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein nein nein nein which is
interesting in actual fact LED does this
thing where he goes what's nein nein
nein nein nein take nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein 8 nein nein nein nein
nein nein actually he actually does this
and I actually counted be a number of
times he said nines and eight eight nine
nine nine nine nine
known and it's unbelievable he's like a
one-off one place of actually having one
of these glitch primes that would have
really made that nerds excited so now
what we have is a way to actually
understand this number so now we have 10
to the 5 0 6 tape and I'm just going to
order it in terms of magnitude here take
that take that
basically what you what you need to
notice here what's going on is the fact
that if you double to 5/3 253 guess what
you get 2/3 is a 6 to 25 so it's
actually that number so now we can
actually find a structure so I'm going
to put in a couple of letters here to
denote other things so I can actually
make it even smaller if you check this
out maybe not in actual fact 4 M now you
have mathematicians this is make it more
more complicated so in actual fact it
actually has this shape so what happened
next I started doing this at 9 p.m. I
mean I was I was still doing it at 6
a.m. I mean I was going down this is the
hole I want to take you down so now
what's really interesting is that if you
if you learn about how to factorize
polynomials or even you know factorize
things because this is actually 10 M
squared take 10 m take 1 so you kind of
get this taught at school you know it
actually has the shape of x squared take
X take 1 so you could actually think oh
maybe I'm going to be able to work out a
way to see when this is a prime or not
see this is what's amazing about these
Prime's Prime's don't act that way a
natural fact I needed to put this number
into like a data base that would crunch
it for me and you wouldn't believe
there's only a small number of M's which
will actually give you this particular
shaped glitch Prime and they happen to
be the values of M where m is equal to 1
6 9 154 253 Oh
1114 and 1390 and that's as far as the
database went and I think that's
probably as far as we know at this point
for this particular so look at that
think about how big this number is how
many values of M you can have and it's
only for these numbers that this will be
Prime and that happens to be prime
what's cooler than just a glitch isn't
good
well maybe but maybe also what happens
if the glitch was right in the middle of
the number so I actually looked into
that as well so that's a different
formula so that formula then is we're
saying it's 10 to the 2m plus 1
take 10 M or take 1 it basically has to
be an odd number of digits not an odd
number but in terms of the number of
digit there has to be an odd number
because it has to have a middle so there
are lots of different values for that
but there's actually a really nice value
the first one we can find is actually M
equals 9 and so what it looks like is 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 & 9 8 and then 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 so it's nine nines eight nine nine
come on
swish but see I looked at this and I
thought glitch what it glitches it we
think glitches we think we think
computers we think binary so really
where this took me tours like I'm
looking at these glitch Prime's the
wrong way I should be looking at binary
glitch primes so I want to look at the
binary numbers so in that fact in that
case I'm looking at instead of nines I'm
looking at one one one one one one one
glitch 1 1 1 1 1 and all and all so
let's just think about the coolest thing
a palindrome and they've actually got a
special name
they're called Cyclops numbers so for
example 5 is 1
zero-one cyclops because it's got a hole
in the middle but you've got lots of
other cyclops numbers i mean i don't
even have to work it out you could have
like two ones in a zero and two ones
whatever that is or you could have three
ones and a zero three ones are you could
have like four and a zero and four I
mean this is getting you know we're
really I mean this is the sort of stuff
you communicate with aliens about you
know what I mean
well that was my question I wanted to
know if other ones could be Prime and
this is really where my mind was blown
because I then had to change the
structure of this thing here it's ten
because it's base 10 but if we actually
do it like this
so if then if it's 2m because we're
basically doing an in binary so that
just means that we need to do it in in
power too right
what that means is this is unbelievable
I'm able to actually factorize this into
2 M + 1 + 1 2 2 m take 1 so you're
always able to do that because it's -
you can't do that with any other number
higher than 2 and this is a problem
because guess what Prime's by definition
don't have any factors they don't have
any factors it's just only divisible by
themselves on one so if you can actually
turn this always into this the only time
this is not going to be a prime is when
one of these things is equal to one so
this is getting added it has to be 2m
take one equals one so then that means
it's two M equals two and come on it's M
equals one so that means it's that means
the only prime we have is 2 to the power
2 plus 1 5 so where this took me
unbelievable the morning the sun's
rising and I realize maybe I'm the first
person to realize
really but that's how I feel about maths
that the only glitch Prime you can have
in binary is 101 we'd like to thank
audible.com for their support of this
numberphile episode if you want to enjoy
a book or other spoken material audible
has everything you could wish for
they've got over a hundred and eighty
thousand titles to choose from and
they're offering a 30-day free trial
when you sign up for the service now if
you're in the mood for some more
mathematics I can highly recommend these
books on the screen including alex's
adventures in numberland and the
mathematics of love both by people who
appear in numberphile videos or if all
this talk about cyclops has you excited
why not go old school and listen to none
other than the Odyssey by Homer not that
Homer if you do check out audible and I
highly recommend it I use audible myself
then use the URL audible.com slash
numberphile that means if you do take
them up on that free trial the good
people there will know you came from
here
that's audible.com slash numberphile and
a sincere thanks to them for helping us
make more numberphile videos